Woah...
Welcome back, master and lady!
Hello everybody!
Hi!
How's the voice?
It's getting a little better.
It sounds a little better than before.
Maybe.
I still sound like I have a stuffy nose.
But I don't!
When I sound like, my voice is a little raspy still.
But it's okay.
I'm not even sick!
I'm not even sick, I just...
The glasses match perfectly.
I know!
I blame Paula.
Me too.
Me too!
It's a cute voice.
Stop it!
What nose?
Are we really doing this right now?
Anyways, hello everybody!
Welcome to Half-Life.
Full life consequences.
That's the only thing I know about this entire series.
No, that's a lie.
I also know...
Gary...
Gordon Freeman.
My favorite cute maid playing my favorite game series.
Let's go!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
I know nothing about Half-Life.
And I was like, trying to decide.
This probably came out of super left field for people.
Why is she playing Half-Life all of a sudden?
And I was looking through my Steam library.
What am I going to play this week?
I'm finishing up Devil May Cry.
I'm finishing up Metal Gear Peace Walker.
I was like...
And then I saw that I have all of Half-Life.
And I was like, well, that's a series I've never played before.
And I really like playing things that are influential in the gaming sphere.
So, I was like, you know, maybe I'll check it out.
It's peak.
Yeah.
Impeccable taste.
Old?
I didn't say old.
You said old.
I did not say old.
I didn't say old.
You said old.
Half-Life is a good choice.
Yeah, so it kind of came out of left field probably.
I haven't talked about wanting to play it at all or anything like that.
It's in the same universe as Portal, by the way.
I love Portal.
I recommend checking out Freeman's Mind and Accursed Farms.
Oh, buy Accursed Farms after this.
Very good fandom.
Before I...
Yes, I don't know anything right now.
I'm probably going to forget everything, literally everything that you guys tell me about.
I'm going to forget about literally everything you guys tell me about.
Because I don't know anything.
The lore is not complicated.
It's not?
I feel like there's so much Half-Life...
Oh my gosh, thank you for all the superchats.
I've got to read them in a second.
I feel like there's so much Half-Life...
Content everywhere, you know?
I don't know what is Half-Life...
What is in the universe of Half-Life...
What is Gary's mod...
What is Team Fortress...
It's all the same stuff, no?
I don't know.
Right?
Half-Life is one of the greatest FPS's ever made?
Really?
I mean, I'm a Doom fan, so...
I rec...
Fun fact, I went to high school with the guy who made Full Life Consequences.
What?
He and his friends introduced me to the series.
Half-Life 2 is one of my all time favorites.
Woah!
Royalty.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Mine was yesterday.
Happy birthday, JPC!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, JPC Shade.
Happy birthday.
Have you played Signalus?
Oh, I have played Signalus.
Interesting man, but thank you for the recommendation.
Not counting Metal Gear, is this the oldest game you are making a full run of?
With Doom?
Wait, when did Doom come out?
Doom...
I think Doom is the oldest.
Yeah, 1993.
Doom is the oldest game probably that I've done.
Yeah, yeah.
When did this?
98, no?
StarCreator, thank you so much for the pink!
John Freeman, who was Gordon Freeman's brother...
Was one day in an office typing on a computer.
He got an email from his brother that Minfantome was about to stream.
So yeah.
Yes.
I'm gonna do my best.
I'm not really a...
FPS person.
But I'll do my best.
We'll see how this goes.
The story isn't that important.
The only thing you have to remember is that all of Skippity Toilet is 100% canon.
Yeah!
Skippity Toilet is also this!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to get in the young crowd.
To watch my streams.
Now we need you to play Halo.
I do want to play Halo eventually.
Dr. Gravity, thank you for the hot guy sample!
I love Half-Life.
One of my favorites of all time.
Playing Half-Life and not Black Mesa is like playing Twin Snakes instead of MGS1.
That's why I'm playing the original Half-Life and not Black Mesa.
Because I did see some people being like...
Why isn't she playing Black Mesa instead?
Isn't it like the remake of the first one?
But I was like...
Well, you know...
I wanna at least play Half-Life and Half-Life 2.
I know there's like some other...
Other games in between and everything.
Not extensions.
Expansions and stuff and stuff.
Yeah, I do kind of...
Putting it...
When you put it in Metal Gear terms, I understand completely.
FPS.
Mint Phantoms per second.
The series is arguably the MGS of FPS games.
So I hope you appreciate it.
That?
Okay.
Okay, arguably.
Arguably.
Weird comparison.
No, it's not.
This is a...
I'm curious why there's no sound on the menu.
That was a...
Controversial take, maybe.
Who's making that argument?
Have fun!
Enjoy the bongs.
Half-Life uses purely environmental storytelling.
So listen to the dialogues and explore.
Turn off the updated models for the OG experience.
I don't...
I don't know if I have them on or...
I don't know if I have them on or not.
But we should...
Get into it.
The screenshot sound...
When you pressed up on the menu freaked me out.
Can you guys hear anything?
I can't.
Let's just...
There we go.
Select difficulty.
Is this game hard?
It's old, so I assume it's really difficult.
Wait, should I go to the training room?
Maybe?
No.
It has hard parts.
Hard mode is really hard.
Easy.
Set medium.
Medium, I imagine, is like normal, right?
Play training.
Okay, let's try the training room.
Not the Steam logo.
Why is it so...
Minky, Minky, Minky...
Anonymous!
Thank you!
Have fun!
Telling someone to play Black Mesa first is like...
Telling someone to play...
You guys have a hive mind.
MP3 volume!
Let's turn this down a little bit.
Hopefully that changes it.
Who copied me?
That's funny.
Do you think that's okay?
There's a man!
Okay!
Thank you!
Hold on, I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit more.
Let's turn it down to like...
Here.
I don't know what the suit volume is.
I feel like the game is loud in general.
Lady in a suit.
Let's go!
God!
Oh my god!
We are so fast!
I'm gonna get motion sick.
Hello lady.
Oh my suit!
Oh I got my suit on!
Oh I'm still alive!
To use your key press A button.
I'm pressing.
Let's begin by stepping into your suit.
You can see it suspended up ahead of you.
If you see one of these buttons, press it.
And I will appear to demonstrate certain moves.
She got that Laura Croft build.
How's the volume now?
Oh.
Sounds good.
I'm inside her.
We are so fast!
Holy cow!
Here we go.
Ew,
we got the nerds watching.
Why is she red like that?
She's a hologram!
lol
Holy cow!
Stealth mode.
I keep hearing hebsuit instead of hevesuit.
Why are they...
What are you doing up there?
You stinking nerd!
Come down here and talk to me.
Like a man!
Okay.
Thank you!
What is...oh so then there is also...
Like...
Run automatically and then this is like...
Not...okay.
Ho!
I'm gaming!
Crouch mid-jump will allow you to reach places easier.
Like that.
To get into these pipes...
You will have to signal your suit...
To make a duck jump.
You'll want to stand right at the mouth of the pipe...
And continue to press forward.
She's still talking.
Yeah, yeah lady.
I'm a gamer.
Thank you mom.
A duck jump.
Wait, what is this?
Kind of ominous, no?
This is part of the training.
I can't tell if the game is glitching...
Or if her hologram is getting worse.
I can't tell if it's because it's an old game...
Or if it's...
I don't know.
Yes.
What's over there though?
Wait, but what's this way?
And...
That's where I was?
Ah, ok.
Yeah, what if I can't?
Lady.
Sarah, welcome to my worship.
Thank you.
Thanks for the 5 gift dude!
What was that?
Oh my gosh.
Yo, I'm a gamer!
Yes.
Ok.
Is that what I look like?
Wait ma'am, can you do it again?
Pressing...
Wait, hold on.
Can you do it one more time?
That's what I look like.
Oh, I gotta get the jetpack.
Oh, I'm so fast.
Holy mo...
Oh.
Oopsie.
Wait, so what's it?
I gotta...
Charge it?
She said?
Duck then jump.
Crouch.
Forward.
Jump.
Oh!
I don't...
I don't think I did it in the correct order though.
Oops!
Just kidding.
Thank you, thank you.
Save to see you playing this.
My recommended play order is Half-Life 1.
And expansion is Half-Life 2.
Wait, hold on.
And episode is Portal, Portal to Alex.
Oh, Alex is the...
The VR one, no?
Hmm.
VR.
Maybe I could, maybe once I get my...
Maybe I could do that with like a 3D setup.
You know?
Good morning mint day!
Today is my birthday!
So I'm spending on things like...
Things I like, like mintos.
Is there a cafe mate?
Can I order some mint cake?
With a slice of maid-o-magic and a coffee, please.
Do you know, kiddo?
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, DnL Kero!
Here is your moe-moe-kyun!
Maid-o-magic!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Thanks for the donate!
No!
Oh!
That's what...
You guys are liars!
This is where I was going, not where I was!
Press backwards key.
Oh, I see.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
What's the use key?
Don't forget to watch full life consequences.
Yeah, I know that one.
Why is there blood back there?
Wait a second.
I think this is kind of important.
Okay, I pressed E before you guys even said it.
Oh, there is like hand print on the wall.
This doesn't seem...
Make me healthy!
Gorgeous freedom.
I just turned 46.
Could you mean to beat me in the dust?
Wait, does that mean it's your birthday?
Or fragile?
Sorry, my voice is kind of icky today though.
You will find medkits like this one throughout the Black Mesa compound.
To restore your health, walk up to a medkit and press your use key.
Your health will recover gradually until you are at full health or the kit is depleted.
Once the light goes out, a medkit cannot be reused.
Since my voice is kind of messed up a little bit, I might not be able to do happy birthday songs.
I'll stop after the kitties one.
But for now, I'm sorry I won't be able to do them for probably the next couple of days.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
But Arkham Jack, happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Arkham Jack!
Oh, Hanta!
Thank you for the raid!
I'm about to sing happy birthday.
Wait, you sent for a story about my cats.
My cats...
My cat!
Thank you for the gift!
Paperbox, thanks for the five gifted!
My cat!
What did she do?
What did she do today?
That's kind of funny.
Thank you, CF2!
Thanks for the gifted!
Did I miss one?
I feel like I missed one.
Oh, Dorgo!
Sorry!
Thank you for the five gifted!
Bugbug!
Thanks for the gifted!
Ducky!
Sound is so nostalgic, isn't it?
Old.
Why is there a health thing here?
I'm spinning.
I think it's timed.
Uh oh.
Wait.
Thanks.
I'm pretty good.
Probably.
In case you fall.
What's over here?
Anything?
I keep feeling like there is going to be something secret to explore in this area.
No?
Push that box down into the pit.
Pushing is easy.
What was that?
No training only?
We got bugs in here!
If you can't push the obstacle out of your way, you might try pulling it.
To pull a box, move up to it and press your use key.
While holding down the use key to keep a grip on the box, move slowly backward.
The box will come along with you.
Thank you!
Cool gaming game.
Maybe check out Half-Life VR.
But the AI is self-aware whenever you have time.
I will!
Thank you!
I'll try to remember.
Get in the box.
Oh no, we have puzzles now.
Oh gosh, I'm not very...
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
What am I?
Pest control here?
Can I get this one too?
Oh, wait.
I think I did.
Mata, no!
Mata, yes!
Oh gosh, this is so...
This is so tricky.
I always start on you singing happy birthday to someone.
There's a lot of birthdays going on.
You can try breaking the objects in your path.
Make sure you picked up the crowbar.
Then simply smash your way through the debris.
Yeah!
We got it!
Ew,
there's more bugs in there.
I think we have to...ok, break, crouch and break.
We have so much power now.
Activate your suit flashlight for the next area.
Fifteen percent.
Ew, this is scary.
Oh, this is really scary.
Oh, I don't like this.
Is this a horror game?
Ok.
Is this truly an FPS when all I need is the crowbar?
Oh, loading.
Yes.
Oh, what is this?
Oh my gosh, there's so much stuff.
Oh, I don't think I can take anymore.
Ok.
What a coincidence.
I played Black Mesa last week.
The flashlight recharges if you turn it off for a while.
Oh, that's good.
That's good to know.
Ah yes, your average science based training for a big corporation.
Of course!
What could go wrong?
How do you...
To fire your grenade launcher, use your alternate fire button.
Certain targets will break only when hit by grenades.
Commencing sequence in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Sorry.
Wait, hold on.
Scared the heck out of me.
Who
am I killing?
Oh.
I'm not doing a very good job with...
Oh, breakable.
I'm not doing a very good job hitting these guys, but...
In the neck.
In the shoulder.
Unbreakable?
Wait, if it's unbreakable...
In her mouth!
Over the glass?
Oh!
I see, I see, I see.
Give your cats kisses for me instead.
Thank you kitties!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, I forgot about...
Hold on.
What did you say?
Uh oh.
It sounds like that was important.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot about a story about my cat.
She recognizes the sound...
Well, no.
She's just a silly goose.
She was really needy today.
And she was making all sorts of chirps and everything.
Ouch.
What?
Was I supposed to land in the water?
What are you doing?
Swim on to the end of the course?
Oh, okay.
What were the controls again?
Oh.
Alright.
Easy enough.
You managed to avoid drowning.
Crazy how fast the load times are nowadays.
Nice.
It's a lot of water down there.
Certain types of damage will register on your heads up display.
Direction of damage indicator.
Ouch.
Ouchy ouch.
We probably shouldn't touch that.
Oh god.
Can I heal?
I think I'm gonna die.
This is quite the tutorial.
It's so long.
Mint doesn't need to hear all this.
She's highly trained professional.
Yeah, everyone's been saying that.
I know it's probably part of the game, but it's making me feel good.
A man!
A lady security guard intervenes in your system.
You must approach a guard and press your use key.
He will follow you until you face him and press the use key again.
What do I do?
Restart.
For those coming into the stream, death count is 52.
What are you talking about?
Ah.
I didn't know if he was a bad guy or not.
He's probably fine right now.
Just kill me!
Kill me!!!
He will let you back into the transit system.
You must approach a guard and press your use key.
He will follow you until you face him and press the use key again.
He will let you back into the transit system.
You must approach a guard and press your use key.
He will follow you until you face him and press the use key again.
He will let you back into the transit system.
You must approach a guard and press your use key.
He will follow you until you face him and press the use key again.
Let's see, load...auto.
This is not a hot dog moment.
This is a first for me.
Impressive.
I guess we'll give it a go.
I think it's going to be the same, no?
You finished the tutorial.
Yeah!
We finished the tutorial.
You guys, I think we're fine.
I think I know everything that I need to know.
I think we're good, right?
Let's go play Half-Life.
New Mexico!
Early.
Oh, look.
The tutorial finished you.
I hope you enjoyed that.
Hello, Gordon.
This is so cool.
I feel like I'm in a theme park.
Can I leave this thing?
Oh god, I'm stuck.
This machine does not follow the laws of physics.
I'm in motion.
I shouldn't be flying backwards.
How are we going down?
Whoa, whoa.
That guy is running.
They haven't invented the laws of physics, so chill.
Let's go!
Hide me.
You guys are so broke bro.
No, you guys brought it up first.
I was thinking it's just a little elevator.
That's me.
He's only 27?
He looks like he's 35.
Wow.
What's that?
It's so cute.
Oh my god.
I love robots.
Oh.
This is so cool.
This world building is so fun.
Oh my gosh.
This is so fun.
Yeah, we know.
This is so cool.
Cool.
Feels really...oh we are going down.
We are going down, down.
Watch out!
That guy!
Oh!
Is he going in there?
Too bad.
I think this is our stop.
Exciting!
Ok.
I think I'm naked.
I don't think I...
Well, this thing was so slow and all the robots were in my way.
The world building in this game is incredible.
Hello sir.
Here, I'll walk with you.
Can we do this later?
Hey, catch me later.
I'll buy you a beer.
Let me in!
Nerd MintoQ?
Did you just say nerd?
We love Barney.
Is that his name?
Oh god.
Barney's teeth are like kind of...
Ok.
Bye bye!
Every guard is Barney.
Anomalous materials.
Really wanted to take the time to flex.
Cutting edge hardware.
Yeah, this whole intro sequence was incredible for 1998.
Yeah, I mean...
Hello.
Ok.
What are you doing?
Oh dang, I'm really late.
Use his keyboard, can you?
Sorry.
What's this do?
Just one of those days.
Sorry.
Wow, you can interact with everything!
Wouldn't it be fantastic to get some pure readings for a change?
I have no doubt.
Well, not everything.
What about you?
Shut up.
Why did you say that?
He just looked over and said shut up at me.
Are you running those tunneling lattice calculations again?
Shut up.
They are so sassy.
Oh my god, no wonder you have...
No wonder you look like that.
He stressed his hair off.
Paul, look at your hairline.
What about you?
You like me, right?
Ok, let's go.
So rude, I know.
Oh, hello.
I just...
I was saying hi!
I think this is about how the graphics and tech have changed.
It will be in 6 years, Half-Life 2.
I just love that with old games.
Oh, hello.
Someone nice.
Oh, ok.
Bye bye.
Ah, hello Gordon Freeman.
Oh, ok.
You are so busy shimmying on me.
That looks important in there.
Mr. Business Suit.
I don't know which way I'm actually supposed to go.
Keep looking.
Things do not look like they are going well.
Santiago, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
The power stance.
Is he going to kill him?
He looked at us, didn't he?
Wait, I didn't see him look at me.
Evening Freeman.
Sorry, I missed it.
You saw it?
Ok, I'll go back in the vault and see it.
I'm knocking on the window.
What are these guys doing?
Eggs.
Oh, hello.
Periodic table.
They are a hive mind.
Hello Gordon Freeman, things are rather busy today.
Stop, please.
I'm so embarrassed.
Oh, there is another guy.
Wait, what do they look like?
They are a pretty average tie, no?
Kind of crazy how... wait, what?
Oh, sorry.
How Half-Life captures my work day.
Why do we have to wear these ridiculous ties?
They look fine to me.
Oh, wait.
Wow,
it took you a second.
We can go... coolant reserve facility.
I don't think this is where I need to go, right?
Why not?
Ok, Barney.
Yeah, I'm holding you to that.
What a good day today.
It is.
I have a feeling things are gonna be...
Oh, there is a stomper over here.
I'm watching Mint with the science team.
I have a feeling today is gonna be the greatest day ever.
Ok.
Straighten him up.
Stop, stop, stop.
All the scientists in the test chamber are waiting for Gordon Chan to get us.
Yes!
Ok,
I gotta go get my hazard suit.
I gotta suit up.
That looks like a suiting up area.
What's in here?
Oh, this also looks like...
I like how they repeat your name over and over and over again.
Oh look!
Are these not the people that...the devs?
Are these not the devs?
This is...this is my locker.
I'm a cow and this is a cheese colored super burrito.
Thanks cow!
Why is my locker there?
Oh, uh oh.
I see somebody in there.
Hey!
Coomer is the name of that scientist, not model.
Uh oh.
Oh, well let me in.
Is somebody in there?
Oh, it's a book.
Who is talking while they are taking a shit?
I just can't stop it.
They are so loud.
Hold on, I want to see what the other area was too.
Is this the ladies room?
Oh, this is the break room.
Sorry.
Give me my drink.
I'm getting scammed.
Hello?
Soda, soda pop.
My god, what are you doing?
He is on his break.
Alright, let's go suit up.
Soda, soda pop.
Yeah, I saw these names in the...oh there is me!
In the...
I have a baby?
The orchid eater?
And the...
The 37th mandala.
I have a kid?
Wow, my kid.
He's got a full head of hair.
I am the kid.
I'm so fast, sometimes it's hard to...
Hold on.
The barrel.
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Technology!
Oh, there is the helicopter.
Wow!
Technology, working as a team.
I saw all three of those guys today.
PowerPoint animation.
Safety!
Yeah!
What else we got?
Black Mesa.
I like this one.
Security force.
The dam.
I'm so fast.
Well,
damn.
Damn.
Another day, another dollar.
Gosh, it's hard work being me.
What's down here?
Oops.
We're fine.
I could have just taken that.
But seriously, what is down there?
Maintenance access.
Oh, oh.
You're dying in places I didn't know were possible.
You can check.
Nothing yet?
Ok, we won't deal with it yet then.
Hello.
Fairy?
Thanks for all the superchats you guys.
You may find out.
Oh, theory.
Who can say?
Oh, this guy is so guilty.
You ate all the donuts.
You!
Control room, test lab access, plasma cells, ionization chambers.
Hello, scientist man.
Laser tubes.
Ok, cool.
Hi.
I'm going in.
Caution laser, caution laser.
Oh, control room.
Test chamber.
They're waiting for you, Gordon.
In the test chamber.
In the chest.
Access denied.
Oh, come on.
How is every line so iconic?
Uh oh.
That doesn't seem good.
Should I go in there or...
Finally the next test subject.
I can fix it.
This doesn't seem very good.
Am I going to be ok?
Wait.
There we go.
Wow, what a cool elevator.
A new man.
If it's beneath the surface of the earth, OSHA can't see it, so it's legal.
So true.
He said the test results seemed fine, but our machinery is literally blowing up.
Is there subtitles?
Gaben.
Thank you.
Ok, hold on.
I saw something.
It's my birthday.
I would like to inquire as to what birthday service is...
Random person, happy birthday!
Usually I could sing you a song, but not today.
I could give you a moe moe energy beam for your cake.
Moe moe beam!
Oh god my throat.
One more time.
Moe moe beam!
There you go.
What is that?
Am I going in the cage?
Oh shoot, I went in the cage.
Wait.
Damn, I don't think I can get in.
Am I going in...
Everything seems to be in order.
Hope you do new save often to avoid death loop.
I didn't know that was a thing.
I will do that.
F6 is a good...
Wait, is it F5 or F6?
I'll try F5.
F6?
Ok, it's not F5 you guys.
It's F6!
Everybody is saying F5, but it's F6.
It's Alt F4.
What's happening?
F7 is quick load.
Thank you.
3, 2, 1
Caution laser
Oh my house!
I'm sure it will kill you if you go back in.
Try out the quick load.
Wow, it worked!
Good to know.
I guess I won't go into the beam.
Don't go into the light, Mito!
I won't.
Ok, I won't.
I'm going to balance on this beam.
It's so beautiful, right?
I was just curious.
I just wanted to see what was going on in there.
What am I doing?
Do I push this?
Do I press this?
No.
Just vibe.
Ok.
I see it.
I'm pushing.
I think I messed up.
I didn't mess up.
That wasn't me.
Is there a door I can leave?
I had one job!
Thank you for the pick.
I'm not a scientist.
Wow, lizards!
They are so cute!
Little bugs.
Unforeseen consequences.
What is this?
I like how
the things are bouncing around.
Oh no!
Mr. Man!
Are you ok?
You alright?
You got this.
I'll give him mouth to mouth.
I don't think this guy made it though.
It's suddenly so spooky.
What did you do?
I didn't mean to.
I just thought that it was a really pretty stone.
Everything is fine up here though.
Everybody is fine here.
Hello guys.
I mean mouth to mouth.
OK!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Is that a headcrab?
This is the professional mint phantom.
Look how cute it is!
I saw it earlier.
It's so cute.
It's trying to eat me.
Hello!
Press E to recruit?
I see, I see.
Come, come, come.
Quick save.
Saved.
Are you ok?
That doesn't seem good.
That doesn't seem to...Oh no it's a headcrab.
He's coming for me!
I'm running!
Wait, can I get through there?
OK.
Alright, cool.
Everything kinda gone to shit you guys.
Open up!
Oh my god!
I got him!
There we go.
Nice.
Crowbar baby!
Oh sorry!
Oops!
My bad.
Are you ok down
there?
Hold on.
OK, hold on.
This is how I learn how to use the ladder.
There we go.
Oh see?
There is a battery pack.
Where is the guy though?
Wait, what's this?
Looks like just a piece.
Go.
Oh there is more?
That look nice.
You wanna team up?
Yeah!
Woo!
Half life source...what what?
Crouch and hit the dead ones, yeah?
That's crazy.
That's so crazy.
Come on buddy.
There is a lot of blood around here.
Are you ok?
Let's keep going.
Let's keep going buddy.
Is this thing gonna turn it...
Is this thing gonna wake up?
No?
I think I was getting shot at, no?
I got slapped.
Oh no,
the microwave.
Is he mad about it?
His food is still cooking.
It's called half life because my life will be half of what it is and I'm mean though.
Stop it.
Yeah!
Soda for the whole team!
Oh there they go.
There were soda for the whole team.
What are you doing over there?
Are you scared?
Anybody in here?
Anything?
Oh!
Some bullets.
That's the good stuff.
Damn.
Oh, I smell the bathroom.
I think we should go.
Wait, do any of these open though?
I actually didn't check.
Yeah Barney, that's poop.
Oh!
Another one.
Let's go.
Nice.
My kid.
Wait, there was... Oh this thing.
My little canister fell down.
Wow, the attention to detail is so crazy.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Is my buddy coming?
Come on.
What are you doing?
Let's go.
There you go.
Come on.
Little steps.
There you go.
I heard something squashing.
I got scared.
I'm save scumming.
Sorry.
Wait, it's gonna go after that guy.
I killed it.
Oh, I killed him too.
It was self defense.
Probably.
I don't know who is infected and who is not.
Right?
Ai yai yai.
Ai yai yai yai yai.
Beep beep beep beep.
Nothing works.
OK, I leave.
Don't go in there Barney.
OK.
I seem to have fixed it.
Oh, that opened up a hole.
OK, hold on.
Before we go in there, let's go to the other side.
Yeah, I saw...
Oh, what the heck?
What was that?
OK, that was just showing us how to get through.
Got it.
Phantom does not need to hear this.
She is a trade professional.
Come here.
Pspsps.
Yeah.
Everything is back to normal now.
Exactly.
I can report it here.
Never mind.
But he can't crawl through.
He is a little silly.
Uh oh.
I just watched that happen.
I was too late.
I don't think it will let me in.
This is kind of spooky you guys.
I'm not going to lie.
He is like, I'm just trying to watch anime.
OK.
Something is giving me a headache.
Not the eggs.
Oh my gosh!
No, Coomer!
You were so young.
Please let me out.
There we go.
Wait, are you alive?
Oh no!
No!
He was almost there.
He died.
You were so good.
How do I change between weapons?
Oh, there we go.
I'll kill it.
I'll kill it dead.
These things are really tough.
Hello?
Rescue?
I see.
Thank you.
Oh, I can crouch through here.
That doesn't seem like a good sound.
Oh, cute.
Oh gosh!
That's what that thing is doing.
OK.
Sheesh.
Oh my god.
He seems awfully calm for everything that's going on here.
Is there like auto-aim on?
It's freaking me out.
Auto-aim is really getting to me.
How do I turn it off?
The options.
Let's see.
A keyboard.
Oh, aim.
Auto-aim.
Yeah, let's not do that.
Let's not have that.
Is there like a reload I need to do?
Oh, I could've pushed this.
Uh-oh, I just pushed into a corner.
I hope I didn't need that.
So this area is death?
Oh my gosh.
OK, they weren't kidding.
Oh, I hear another.
I hear it.
What am I hearing?
What the heck is that?
Oh my god.
At least it dies easily.
Holy cow.
Good golly.
OK, I don't know which way I want to go.
I'm trying to figure it out.
OK.
I know I can get in through here though.
Maybe I'm just bad.
There we go.
Let's go this way first.
Oh my gosh!
Scared the heck out of me.
Can
I please get out?
Hello.
Maybe I should've shot the...Oh, hello mister.
Are you OK?
Yes.
Yup.
Alright.
Give me a second mister.
Yeah, yeah.
Give me a second.
Oh shoot, he soft locked me.
Wait, hold on.
Can you move?
Thank you.
There we go.
Let's go back.
I think he's going to use...I'm going to need him to open a door over there.
I'm assuming...I'm assuming...I just want to take a look around in here first.
What I was saying is...
That's so...
I think I got him.
Are you OK in there?
Come on out.
Oh, but you said let's go.
OK.
Freaking liar over here.
That seems more permanent than where we were headed before.
So let's go back.
Come on mister.
OK.
Don't go down yet.
Yeah, I'm not.
I'm not.
You seem like I can blow them up.
I'm scared to though.
Nevermind.
Look at him picking like a gorilla.
All is safe.
Oh, thank you.
Oh.
OK.
Nice.
Wait.
So...
Grenades is...OK.
Crowbar, gun, grenade is 5.
OK.
Oh, sorry.
Wait.
I never learned how to use the grenade.
Yeah, but why is the crowbar gone?
It won't select it.
You can...click to select.
Ah, I see.
I see.
I right clicked before.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Instead of singing a song, can I get a YOLOLO?
Also lighten the mood during this disaster.
Fancy pants lizard!
Happy birthday!
YOLOLO!
OK, mister.
I don't think I need you anymore.
Just in case.
Oh, sorry.
Everything is fine.
That guy was dead.
Don't worry about it.
OK, bye.
I'm going to stay here and wait for my colleagues.
Yep, that's what I told you to do.
And what about you?
Stinky.
This is pretty freaky, guys.
Not gonna lie.
My flashlight does not work there.
Why do we even have the sewers like this?
That seems like it will raise the water.
Don't forget to do a quick save.
Yeah, thank you.
Thanks for reminding me, guys.
Appreciate it.
Hello?
Oh gosh.
I can't...I can't see.
I can't...I can't...I'm trying to...
That was close.
Einstein of the dumpster.
What is your wisdom?
Don't drink the green water.
Are there bosses in this game and stuff?
And more cheese.
Thanks, Cal.
Thank you.
Are
you OK?
Oh no!
That scared me.
I think I missed my...
I think I missed my stop.
It won't come for me, will it?
Wait,
I think I'm in trouble, you guys.
Wait, I think this is actually pretty bad.
Rain
of crabs!
I thought there was just the two of them.
Oh, the grenade.
Yes, thank you.
That didn't seem like I did that correctly.
OK, hold on.
Third time's the charm.
Oh, you are so annoying.
Shut up!
Oh, I could use these for getting up to the first aid.
We'll just leave these little guys alone.
They don't seem to be bothering anybody, you know?
Oh, I might want that though, actually, now I think about it.
OK, hold on.
I have a lot of ammo.
OK.
Wait, is this big enough?
Wait.
No, I don't think I can... Wait.
Is this tall enough?
I don't think so.
I think I
messed...
I can walk it.
What do you mean I can walk it?
It scared me.
You can hold E.
No, you can't.
E and walk.
I give up.
Let's just hope for the best.
OK.
Logan, thank you so much for the time gift.
Thank you!
I
think I fractured something.
Understandable.
OK.
Very good.
Wait, should I have gone down that first one, I wonder?
Let's go.
Oh, that doesn't look...
Oh my god, he just killed it.
Yeah, kill the... Wait.
Let's have him kill the headcrabs.
Ouch.
OK.
I can jump across.
Wait, I wanted him to...
I wanted him to kill the other guys, but he noticed me.
Got his ass.
What the headcra...
Look at him...
What is that?
That's not a headcrab.
What is that thing?
He killed this one at least.
OK, I think I'm going to have to go down.
I still don't remember... Hold on.
I don't quite remember the...
This one.
Oh no.
Nasty water.
I think I messed up.
What are you?
I don't have the jetpack.
Oh, you're right.
Use your arms, Gordon.
Oh wait, I'm using my arms.
Oh
my gosh, I thought it was a rope.
That's so funny.
We're OK.
Oh my gosh, I see them now.
Come here.
Oh shoot, I did it again.
Don't mind me.
Wow.
If he comes into a spinning... Oh, they're both spinning.
You're spinning me right round, baby, right round.
Wait.
Well, I guess this one I can go on.
We made it.
Is there anything down here?
Let me check.
Crimson, thanks for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh, I
just realized there is another door there.
My bad.
You guys, sayonara!
Is that mine?
Wait, I don't think I can live without that.
I think that's like my heart.
I think we have big problems here.
Let's see if this thing can heal us all the way up.
Nah, just walk it off.
We are growing a new heart as we speak.
Wait, there is one over there.
Wait, wait, wait.
Ok, hold on, hold on.
We can get back over still.
Nice.
No, we are not in such good of shape, but that's ok.
It will stop eventually.
No, no, no, no, no, please.
Ok, I messed up.
I messed up.
We probably reek so bad.
This water is... I mean, we probably have grown like three arms at this point from this water.
Hello?
Oh no, parkour.
Parkour moment.
Hi, hi.
Quick save.
I was debating because I kind of want to...
I wanted to go back to my save where I had full health and didn't lose my heart.
Do you know who ate all the donuts?
Who knows?
First try.
Gamer.
Or gaming.
It's quiet here.
Too quiet.
Ok.
I'm going to get ambushed in here.
There's going to be four invisible men.
Ah!
Office complex.
Oh, there
was a guy there.
Oh, it just killed that thing.
Nice.
Kill that guy too.
Ah, nice, nice, nice.
I don't know what's going on there.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
I think everything has gone to hell for real.
What's that sound?
Oh gosh.
Today was... Oh gosh, you guys.
I was three days away from retirement.
This was supposed to be my best day ever.
Ewww!
That guy over there seems fine.
That guy over there seems normal.
Are you ok?
That's it?
Ah, good to see you.
Right.
Looking at her still beating her on the floor.
The suit AI minor fractured.
Yes to you.
Is everything ok?
I thought you disappeared.
I thought he was just a figment of my imagination.
What?
Oh my god!
That was so stinking close.
Holy cow!
Yes sir!
I'm going to get this so that you don't get...
Very good!
Oh snacks!
In her mouth!
You're fine.
What?
A ghost just opened that.
We are free to advance.
Come on.
I think I need you to open this door.
What do you mean?
Oh wait, I need to go in through here.
Ok, hold on.
Nose happy.
Yeah, we turned off the...
We turned it off.
We turned off the power.
The bed?
Ok.
This doesn't seem like I should go into the water.
The room with the electricity.
And the water.
Ok.
What's in here?
Storage?
This game is good with the jump scares.
What is it doing?
Oh, he's just making a mess in there.
Take it.
Take that.
Oh, there's nothing in here.
Wow, that was a waste of my time.
You're wasting my time.
Oh wait, I'm a liar.
Hit his legs.
Thank you.
The roaches.
Smash.
I like destroying everything until it's completely dead.
Uh oh, is this like a puzzle?
Oh gosh, ok.
Maybe not.
Maybe we're ok.
Wait.
Oh god, maybe we're not ok.
Maybe we're ok.
Maybe we're not ok.
Wait, maybe we're ok.
We're ok.
Destroy?
This
is like the biggest cardboard... not cardboard.
Biggest box I've ever seen.
We got it.
Alive man.
Alive man?
Can I come in?
Oh no!
What?
That was just two hits.
I tried, I was too slow.
Should I restart?
Thanks mister.
Yeah, it wasn't you luckily.
What else is down here though?
Oh, what is that?
I think that's a piece of that other guy.
Luckily it wasn't him, right?
Oh nice!
Oh yeah!
Loot!
Good, good, good, good.
Ok.
If you are wondering why everyone calls the guards Barney, it's from the game files.
Same with G-Man.
Thanks!
So true.
I hear something.
Good job Barney!
I was about to be like, behind you!
What is this?
Wait, what is that?
Looks like a smiley face.
What the hell is this?
Come on!
Come with me if you want to live.
Come on.
Can you open this door?
This guy is just chilling.
He is so ominous looking.
Oh my god, there is a person there.
Very nice.
Barney is also the name of the guard you play in one of the expansions called Blue Ships.
I see.
Save first.
So true.
Wait, ok.
Is this actually parkour?
This seems not very good idea.
What am
I trying to get to?
Now that I think about it.
What is my purpose?
Maybe the light switch?
The light switch.
The vent?
I think I need to get the light switch.
I need to turn it off first though, no?
Or will it hurt me?
Aha!
More!
I did the wrong button.
I think we are good.
There we go.
I meant to switch to my gun.
Oh wait, did I just see movement?
No.
This is so scary.
Stupid.
Dummy.
Dummy crab.
Barney, where are you?
I'll stay here and guard this area.
No you won't.
Yeah, yeah, come on.
I don't think... It's like he's stuck.
Are you quivering in your booties Barney?
Come on buddy.
Oh my gosh.
Oh nice, good job.
He's doing his best over there.
Barney!
You got this!
Pull!
He's dancing it out.
He's dancing out the nerves.
Come on!
Actually...this way.
Look, look, look.
There is an opening.
It's right here.
Pull!
Push!
I push from my side.
You pull from your end.
I think we are just going to have to continue onward without him.
Ain't no party like a Barney dance party.
My cat actually does this sometimes.
How many hours until he dies of exhaustion?
He won't!
I feel like I'm watching a Sims glitch.
Yeah, because you think you are running the entire thing.
Come on!
What did you say?
Come on Barney.
Oh wait, he can't even go up.
Nevermind.
Barney, we are going on without you buddy.
Wait.
Oh shoot.
Oh this is so hard.
Oh Valve!
Tell him to stop?
Why?
Oh my God.
OK.
I think this is the way I'm supposed to go.
I believe it is.
Very nice.
Why?
Can I shoot it down myself?
Yeah save.
Let's save real quick.
Use a handgun instead.
Do you think it's better?
It's difficult with the shotgun.
OK.
It's for killing the security guard back in the tutorial.
This is my... These are my full life consequences.
Grenade instead?
OK let's try the grenade.
I feel like I'm nervous.
That did not work.
Peek!
You must reach the Lambda Complex as soon as possible.
I'm working on it!
That was unlucky.
We got it.
Easy peasy.
More paper.
More.
Oh wait.
No, I don't need it.
I got this.
Maybe I don't got this.
I tried the crouch jump.
I think I'm just bad.
There are no smaller boxes.
Maybe in here?
I'll take that.
Nice.
What's in here?
We just went in a big ol' loop.
Wait, now Barney can come.
I don't think the wood crate is...
I don't think the wood crate is any smaller.
Is it?
Let's see.
The wood crate is just as big, you guys.
The one up top.
How do I grab it?
Small box.
Oh, in the Barney area.
Oh, thanks guys.
Eh.
Yeah,
this will be so worth it, you guys.
Wait for it.
Wait for the payoff.
It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be so good.
It's gonna be really good.
I'm stuck on, I think, a body part, maybe.
I think you get stuck on the blood textures, maybe.
I don't know why.
OK.
And there's gonna be... The best weapon is in this box.
Hey, Barney.
Yeah, we will.
He loves to run.
That's his favorite activity.
There he goes.
Run like hell.
He really meant it.
I'm feeling so paid off right now.
What are you talking about?
Let's run.
He made it.
Oh my gosh, Barney, I'm so proud of you.
Come on.
I'll go slow.
I'll walk.
We'll walk like hell.
Oh
my God.
Yes.
Alright, buddy.
Yes!
That's...
Watch out, Barney!
I don't think I got a single one.
That's a lie!
I got one!
So true, Barney.
So true.
Alright, we have you in here.
We got these guys blown up.
Let's keep going.
Are you OK?
Hello other Barney.
OK.
Can I have two of them?
Two of them.
I got it.
Oh, I was going to say there is one behind you.
I'm hearing so many things.
Are you OK?
What's going on here?
I don't think that's what was supposed to happen.
Barney, it couldn't be helped.
What were they trying to do?
Oh, I think he was getting taken and then the other guy was trying to...
OK.
Good job.
That was not good.
Can I get out of your place?
Thank you.
That was not good.
Oh my gosh.
I almost shot you.
Thank you.
Barney is holding his own for real.
These guys are so gross.
I hear sounds everywhere.
I hear...
Watch out Barney.
Don't turn your back on them.
One HP in a dream.
Yeah, I know.
I'm working on it.
There's still more.
There's still...
Did he just say booty shot?
Booty shot.
That's what it sounded like he said.
Oh no, he died.
Death by lamp.
The most pathetic of the...
of the deaths that we've seen.
A tragedy.
Booty shot.
I feel like I should save.
It wasn't me.
It wasn't me Barney.
Definitely not me.
I can get you one, if you like.
Right here.
I got you.
Come here.
There's multiple.
Oh my God, Barney.
Barney.
Barney, are you still alive?
No!
OK Barney, you're alive.
Why didn't you shoot Barney?
Barney move.
Barney out of the way.
Good job.
I'm trying to get Barney his cold one.
For you.
He shimmied.
I think he's excited about it.
Everything is A-OK.
Booty shot.
Guys, I know how to talk to the scientist.
Don't worry.
You've seen me.
I've been playing the game.
Booty shot.
Oh OK.
Oh come on.
Come with me.
Come with me if you want to live.
Is that a softlock or am I...
Am I softlocked or...
No?
OK.
They got booty shot.
Booty shot.
It's so loud.
Start turning this stuff down again.
Booty shot.
Oh no!
That was so funny.
He's just going down the little stairs.
Oh Barney.
Oh scientist.
Shotgun right click is double damage.
Good to know.
It's spelled booty shot of course.
Of course!
Wow!
That really did work.
I probably shouldn't hit the thing that says explosive.
Save and try.
No!
Try and come on me.
Oh it's up there.
Hello.
You're so polite.
Will you come with me then?
I'm not going to die.
Don't tell that to the last Barney though.
I wouldn't promise.
Oh shoot.
Dang it.
Watch out!
Guys I think I need to shut my mouth.
Guys I think I need to start...
Tears going down.
Barney I'm sorry.
Barney is dying and you're laughing.
It was fun while I was the next Barney.
Thanks for all the memories.
Sorry my voice is really starting to give out you guys.
It doesn't hurt in case you're wondering.
It just doesn't sound so good.
I hear noises everywhere.
Oh come on.
Ah!
Dang they do so much damage.
Oh my god.
No way.
I
think the scientist was dead though.
Mint always sounds lovely.
Thank you!
I'll go in there in a second.
I can't...
Can't go in there yet.
Ok.
Oh yes now.
Yeah.
I hear something chirping.
My cat is not in there.
I hear like a...
How do I get in here?
New Barney be like did you boost me?
Oh!
I'm missing out on areas.
Can I make it past?
Ok hold on.
Ok I can't get past that.
Can I get past this?
Oh.
That's not good.
Dang it.
He still got me.
Where are we going guys?
We're fine.
What is that?
Whatever it is.
Oh wait I think it's a headcrab.
Ok, no limbo.
What is...oh!
We made it!
Wow!
I'm so good.
World's...no wonder that guy died from that lamp earlier.
It's like the world's sturdiest lamp ever.
Can I grab this?
Oh I guess I don't need it.
Ok cool.
Oh wait.
Ok!
Time to go into the spooky room.
Oh I had my thing on this whole time.
I'm scared.
What are you doing?
Did I miss?
Oh shoot.
Hold on.
Excuse me.
There we go.
Just a coffee break.
Wow fresh brood.
Very nice.
Killed so hard he fell twice.
I know.
What a bozo.
Such a little weak bozo here.
Are we in the kitchen?
We are in the fridge.
Oh my god.
Some overkill.
Don't slip.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh ok.
I was going to say don't slip but like...
What?
Just chilling eating lunch in the break room.
Maybe it's you who is the real monster.
Oh god.
I'm stuck.
I'm scared.
Ouch.
Headcrabs are so icky.
Let's switch to my pistol.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Ouch.
You can dodge headcrab lunging by strafing.
I see.
Thanks for the heads up.
Barney.
Barney number...
Another Barney.
More Barney.
I don't know where I was coming from.
I think you are way too calm for what was happening here.
Are you alive?
Mr. Scientist?
Oh you are alive.
How
did you live?
There is an energy pack in there.
Calm down you baby.
He is so violent.
I hate boxes.
Whose spine is this?
Someone got like super defleshed.
It's my spine?
Let's go.
Wait a second.
I want to get in there though.
What's this do?
Oh.
Interesting.
I know there is this.
But I don't want to do it just yet.
I want to get back in there.
It's a puzzle.
Is it a puzzle?
Ask the scientist to heal you.
Will he?
Heal me.
I am a fellow scientist.
Oh sorry.
Oh wait.
Only if you are at 25 or below.
I see.
Neat.
Oh.
Duh.
That's how I got in before.
Sorry Mr. Scientist.
Give me a second.
We are going this way.
We will go this way.
And we have to take this.
Once it comes around.
Once it comes back.
You can beat the meat.
Here King.
You drop this.
Hands Barney.
Number 3.
His spine.
Wait.
Can you come back?
Is there a head crab in one of these boxes?
There isn't.
That's actually quite shocking.
I'm scared.
Wait.
Mr. Man.
Mr. Security Man.
I'm going to save real quick.
There is just someone's skull in here.
They are picking it clean.
These guys are starving.
Oh this room doesn't seem very good.
Why is it...oh my...is it these guys?
Another rope.
Yeah.
Unrelated to today's events.
Totally unrelated.
The noise in here is so weird.
Wait.
I can probably just beat this guy.
Beat the meat.
What a weakling.
60%.
Let's go.
Zide.
Zid.
Thank you so much for the 10 Gems.
Thank you.
What am I supposed to do in here?
I think I'm supposed to go up.
Over there?
But I'm bad at jumping.
I don't like the sound in this thing at all.
Sounds like someone poorly strumming a guitar.
Over there.
He doesn't know where to go.
Hi!
We can still climb.
Is this where I was before?
No.
Where am I?
He said...well, he's a little confused.
I hate boxes.
Be there or be square.
We made a big circle.
I see where we are.
Maybe we should go up?
OK.
Nothing seems to be here.
I killed him.
I took some hits though.
I should be used to...
I should be used to the hidden headcrabs by now.
Greetings.
I think you missed most of those shots, Party.
He just dove through the window.
Greetings.
Oh yeah baby!
Sweet.
Sweet health.
There wasn't even anything in here with you.
You just chose to dove through the window for no reason.
Maybe he was trying to get away from...I guess he was trapped in this room.
Excuse me.
Oh!
Just hang in there.
Hang in there.
Hello.
Thank you for the raid.
Hello, hello.
I'm playing.
I'm playing Half-Life for the first time ever.
Is this where we are supposed to go or this way?
You guys see that?
Wait, open up the door.
Open up the door.
G-Man.
Oh my god, why is the guitar string so loud now?
Why
are you so rude?
You talk too much.
I think the audio might be bugged.
Every time they...
I think the audio is bugged.
It's funky.
Oh hello.
It's real funky.
That's just the echo.
Is it really?
Oh I made it.
You got this.
I'm coming for you.
I
don't know why I jumped guys.
Oh.
He is probably just screaming.
Because he is so excited.
I can't...
You got this.
Oh.
Barney looks really suspicious down there.
Not gonna lie.
I watched a Minecraft movie last night.
My opinions on it aren't great.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Seriously?
Who built this?
Uh...
We've got hostiles.
I think we do.
What's going on?
Oh charger.
Let's go.
They panicked.
Yeah.
I can tell.
Oh wait.
Maybe I should go in.
Walk?
What do you mean F6?
I already saved you guys.
I already saved.
Oh my god.
I think I saw a headcrab.
Oh no.
There is just a guy.
Shotgun works well on these.
OK.
Honestly I kind of want to reload so I don't take the damage.
What's this now?
Maybe I should have blocked it with the box.
OK.
Uranium?
Shoot.
Oh shoot.
OK.
Good timing.
Double whammy.
Free soda.
I'm saving?
Alright.
Now we are good to save.
That looks like a good gun in there.
Dang it.
Can I vent?
Wait a second.
Come here table.
Come here.
I pushed too much in the corner.
It's like making a sound but it's not moving.
Maybe I'll go with this one.
Stuck on the body.
I tried.
You can't get up there from here.
Dang it.
Well thanks for saving me.
Some time I suppose.
I think there is another one.
Easy.
First time catching you live and you are playing one of my favorites.
Thank you.
Thank you Jason.
Thank you for the super chat.
Welcome.
Welcome in.
I always forget that I can quick switch like this.
OK.
Teleports behind you.
Nothing personal kid.
Here we go.
How are we getting in?
There is another?
Oh I see it.
I think I just hit the side.
OK.
Imagine those don't activate.
Unless you pass this thing.
But I also am nervous if they would activate if I get too close.
You
can ignore deactivated turrets?
Oh you can.
Dang.
But what if...
I guess if I cross this...
How do I get through this?
I think it might be time.
Nevermind.
Headcrab generator?
Yeah that's what I am thinking.
Alright.
Let's try.
Did I get it?
Uh oh.
No, not the slippery floor.
That's so messed up.
This is so... Wait, this is actually so messed up.
Something happened.
Wait.
Rip the scientist?
I mean...
Nice.
Alright.
This is so scary.
I imagine you shouldn't go down that way.
We made it!
Why are they activated though?
I didn't do anything.
What was that?
There is something up there.
I want to go up there.
I want to go to there.
Why is this guy everywhere?
Gee man.
Okay.
I am gonna touch these.
I guess the turrets are down so it's okay.
Radio check.
What that mean?
Where are you?
What?
I guess this is if you need a hiding spot.
Radio!
Hey I am here!
They are like a nasty alien.
I can hear them knocking at the door.
Search and destroy?
Wait!
Search and rescue.
Thank god you are here.
I think we just got the next gun.
Rescue!
That was the thing we heard.
Was there a way?
I guess I could have saved the guy if...
If I had killed that guy first.
Sorry buddy!
Up we go!
Hey buddy!
Quit running!
You are going too fast!
I am with the science!
What is this?
What is going on here?
That was a lot!
I am just eating bullets here.
Don't hit me!
I am with the science!
Wasn't there a guy up here?
Did I kill him?
Where are you?
Hello!
Yes sir!
What is this?
I'll take that.
This is where I came from?
OK.
I know the music is really quiet.
It's because the game is...
kind of inconsistent with the volume.
There we go.
There you go!
You can have your little soundtrack.
OK.
Wait, I am going to heal fully too.
I don't know what I am thinking.
Nice.
OK.
Let's keep going baby!
We are killing it I feel.
Do not stack.
At least I saved that guy, no?
Evil!
Ewww!
Feeling around with their little tongues.
I love how we have to worry about...
these guys now...
and the monsters.
I hear one.
I think I see him.
Oop!
I
kill you!
Let's go!
What's going on?
This is so typical.
They mess up and then they come in to kill all the people that...
that are the witnesses.
This is so typical.
They are just blowing up by themselves.
Poor nerd.
How do I get through there?
I am going to kill these guys.
I know I am going to accidentally cut them somehow.
I am lost.
So lost.
I don't understand what the charge is for.
I know it's for my flashlight, but what else?
Because I am not using my flashlight right now.
Oh my armor!
My shield!
Here I am thinking it's a different thing.
Power armor.
Maybe they blew themselves up.
I see now.
I don't think I can go that way.
I am getting it just in case.
There are two of them.
We got one, no worries.
Where is the other one?
Just drop a grenade down there.
OK!
Oh I see it.
I don't think I got it.
Maybe I shouldn't have done it.
OK, I'll drop the grenade over here.
Is that a soft lock or...?
I think I messed up.
Oh shoot.
OK.
I did it.
Chill!
Wait, I need my other gun.
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
You guys are alive still, right?
Ouch.
I think they are dead.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
I think they both died.
I'm sorry.
He looks so pathetic there.
Where is the other guy?
OK.
There was a whole other guy, but...
He's...maybe he went up.
The other guy exploded.
I hear I was just coping a little bit.
Oh this is where I came from.
Well, if they hadn't run...
If they hadn't run, I would have been able to do something.
I'm not victim blaming or anything.
I'm just saying that...
Maybe they should have...
Just...
They are running from me because I'm scary.
There is no way here I'll save now.
Maybe not the best place to save.
Maybe I could be doing better, but...
You know, this is my first time playing the game, so...
I know where this is.
Yes.
I'm doing great.
Really.
Let's go.
Better than most streamers I've seen.
I'm not really an FPS player either, so...
I was...Oh.
That was weird.
What is that?
What did I just hit?
A bunch of soldiers.
Dialogue is assembled from a bunch of sound files that are strung together.
Strung together.
To make sentences.
It makes them sound goofy, but it's pretty cool.
Press Q to swap your Alaska.
Oh yeah, I do know the Q.
I'm just...I don't know.
I like to switch guns, so I'm not consistent.
Where the heck am I supposed to go?
Now I'm really lost.
Is that the door I'm supposed to go?
Is it here?
Yes?
What
is that sound?
What does that mean?
Is this a boss?
I'm just standing out here like a stinking sitting duck.
Hold on.
I'm trying to...Oh.
That's what I was doing.
Is
this thing going to bomb me?
I think so.
Fire in the hole!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I was fixing my nose, please.
I don't want the crowbar!
There we go.
Oh, these guys are tough.
Ok, maybe I should switch back to this thing.
You have a nose?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, she's got a nose?
Since when?
Can I just leave?
Access back.
Holy moly.
Wait.
Anything over here?
No?
Ok.
It's so loud.
I'm going to turn it down some.
Ok.
I'm going to leap of faith.
I see you.
Where did you go?
I
didn't move.
Oh, ok.
Where the hell did you come from?
Is the guy still down here?
Oh, yes he is.
Excuse me.
Bye bye.
I'm scared of saving right now.
Because I might want to do that part over.
Ok.
We made it.
Very good.
Let's go.
What's this part?
Hold on.
Let's check out what we got.
Save just in case?
Ok.
I think you are right.
I think I shouldn't do that part over.
I might die.
Serves you right for skipping dialogue.
I'm just out here trying to live my best life in the game.
I don't have a life outside the game because I'm dead.
I can't believe they are trying to kill us though.
You could look at Gordon Freeman and be like, what a nerd.
This guy can't do anything.
Ok, there are so many places to go.
I'm a little overwhelmed.
Oh, booty.
Oh, I heard...
Oh
wait, maybe I can't.
Let's just open.
Booty shot.
Wait, maybe I don't hear a headcrab.
Maybe I hear a little... the roaches.
I think overall that was probably our most important...
Oh, we are here.
Remember I was trying to get up there.
Oh my gosh.
This is where we are at.
You alright?
You ok?
Alright, we made it through.
Cool, cool, cool.
Actually, I'm going to go back to this gun.
Where did...
Is this where I came from?
I think so.
So then I go left.
I drank too much.
Wait, wait.
There we go.
Ok, more ammo.
We'll take that.
This is a bizarre storage area place.
Alright.
Take it slow on the fan.
Wait, go back to the fan.
Like here?
Cool.
I don't think I need to take it slow.
Alright!
Yeah, it stopped for me.
It was like ladies first.
That was kind of silly.
Where do I go first though?
Maybe here?
Oh, hello!
Ok!
I know where we are.
Oh wow, there was literally a single more charge in it.
That's so funny.
But, before I do that...
Wait, can I not go back in?
Oh shoot.
Oh wait, it's again.
There was up.
This one.
Let's check out in here real quick.
Upies, upies, upies.
Just kidding.
Ok.
Nothing here.
Does this even work?
Oh dang.
That would be so crazy if it did.
This doesn't work anymore either.
Guys!
My throat is starting to give out so I might cut it off here.
I think this is an ok point to stop at.
Is this a good stop?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Good progress made.
Yippee!
This has been so fun!
This has been so so so much fun!
I hope you guys are enjoying it too.
I love how just goofy everything is so far.
Don't you too?
Ok.
Alright Mr. Scientist.
It's so fun doing better than I thought.
I'm a bit of a gamer.
If you... would say I'm a bit of a gamer.
I'm a bit of a gamer gal.
I'll give you a close up of my glasses.
My nerd gear.
Check out my new gear.
Thanks for playing a classic.
You are doing amazing for a first timer.
No cap.
Thanks!
I hope your voice keeps healing up.
Thank you.
My glasses.
I have a degree.
In Simpology.
That's right.
I am a simp.
That's Dr. Simp to you.
A Simpology degree.
I am studying Simposis.
The...
Dr. Minky.
You might have Simposis.
That's why I'm studying it.
And I have it too.
For science.
I self-administered it to me.
So that I could study it's effects.
And I only have...
Checks watch.
20...
For...
Checks watch.
No.
24 hours left to live.
My research is not going well.
And...
Yeah.
I would like to...
I will leave...
All my research...
In...
In one page notes.
Scattered throughout my research lab.
Which is...
50 bajillion...
Rooms.
And sometimes there might be little cassette tapes.
That you must listen to.
So...
I'm gonna read...
Or I'm gonna leave my diary.
And all my research and findings in notes.
Scattered throughout the facility.
And...
Yeah, good luck.
Slenderman.
You'll search for them?
I believe in you.
I believe in...
You.
I'm dead now.
Anyway, thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
This is a lot of fun.
I will see you next time we play...
How far am I in?
I actually don't know how long this game is at all.
So...
I think...
How long to beat said like...
12 hours of...
Wait, maybe I'm thinking of a different game.
I don't remember.
Like a quarter?
20%?
Okay.
Not far at all.
Cool.
Because I'm having fun.
So glad you're loving it.
It's one of my favorite games to replay.
I try to at least once a year.
Certified Mito Gaming.
Thank you!
Cool, cool.
First act done.
Let's go!
Yippee!
Not even half.
Okay, cool.
Has 18 chapters.
That's like when we get the little title, right?
I don't even know how many we've gotten.
Was it fun?
It's so much fun!
I'm gonna keep playing next week.
Yes, yes, yes.
Osamito!
Thank you everybody.
See you when I see you next!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
Thank you for watching!
Thanks for hanging out!
Bye-bye!
Nemi is still playing Elden Ring, so I'm going to...
Raid into her.
Lucky!
I always forget to raid.
So I'll raid into Nemi Nightmare!
Yippee!
Yeah.
Tell her she's cute.
Lucky!
Bye-bye!